comme la plupart des membres de son
gouvernement lionel jospin est en
vacances il est arrivé hier soir sur
l'île de ré où il a acheté une maison
l'automne dernier l'occasion pour le
premier ministre de commenter les
mauvais chiffres du chômage publiés hier
et puis de préciser avec quels fonds il
avait acheté cette maison alexandre kara
et philippe ya du vent dans les voiles
une mer calme et un bateau maniable en
somme un beau rêve d'un politique
à n'en pas douter si le capitaine jospin
pouvait gouverner la france comme tenir
la barre de ce voilier il ne s'en
plaindrait pas après le cycliste le
tennisman voici lionel jospin le marin
et lorsqu'on lui parle de dépression
économique ou de creux du chômage
il conserve le discours du capitaine au
long cours quant au chômage
nous avons eu 1 millions 78 mille
chômeurs de moins et il y a eu deux fois
deux mois à plus 5 milles plus une île
je ne m'en réjouis pas mais enfin c'est
sans mesure par rapport à l'amplitude du
mouvement de baisse du chômage est
naturellement de création d'emplois
lunettes de soleil bermuda et chaussures
de bateaux le premier ministre a déjà
tout du vacancier
au programme sport lecture et des temps
dans cette maison de l'île de ré qu'il
vient de s'offrir une acquisition
garantie 0% fonds spéciaux oui mais on
s'est dit que
peut-être au lieu de louer une maison
qui revenait un peu cher mais peut-être
faire un effort supplémentaire en
demandant de crédit à nos banques ce que
nous avons fait ma femme et moi je suis
maintenant il y en a sept petites
maisons dans mars bon merci une
demi-heure avec la presse et voilà le
premier ministre débarrasser de ses
obligations médiatiques jusqu'au 23 août
date du conseil des ministres de la
rentrée
trois semaines pour les vacances de
monsieur jospin le temps sans doute de
méditer un peu sur la grande régate
présidentielle qui se profile déjà à
l'horizon